Now that we know what
bipartite graphs and
matching are, let's consider where that
problem of finding a maximum matching
in a bipartite graph comes up
in real world applications.
Actually, we'll make this a quiz, where
I give you some problem descriptions,
and you tell me which can be cast
as a maximum matching problems,
in bipartite graphs naturally.
Don't worry about whether or
not there's some complicated reduction.
First, consider the compatible
roommate problem.
Here some set of individuals give
a list of habits and preferences, and
for each pair we decide
if they're compatible.
Then we want to match roommates so
as to get a maximum number
of compatible roommates.
Next, consider the problem of
assigning taxis to customers, so
as to minimize the total pick up time.
Imagine that you're a taxi
dispatcher service.
Another application is
assigning professors to
classes that they
are qualified to teach.
Obviously, we hope to offer
all the classes that we want.
And lastly, consider matching
organ donors to patients,
who are likely to be able
to accept the transplant.
Of course we want to be able to do
as many transplants as possible.